I'm going to Finland for spring break
don't let me tell you no rage babe and I
just said to Scott like do you want to
invite Sofia the Kourtney Scott Sofia
saga continues because now we have more
footage to show you of what happens
during Sofia's debut a hunky beam up for
the Kardashians I just said to Scott
like do you want to invite Sophia oh my
god really well I mean we've traveled
together already that's nice of you you
are such a great co-parent er I really
am no I'm not being sarcastic at all
okay so this time it's all told from
Courtney's perspective as she drives and
gets a little road rage with Khloe you
tailing them is not gonna make it them
go faster hilarious but anyways let's
rewind first in the first teaser clip we
saw this went down a really awkward
situation it's bizarre I want you to
annasophia to be comfortable you're
sophisticated with me and Kourtney's
around and now we're hearing more from
Kourtney on why she invited Sophia to
Finland with her family they don't make
me feel like I'm left out though which
is nice that's someone else I wouldn't
like go or invite her to come and of
course we can count on Khloe to be the
voice of reason to raise important
questions which is exactly what happens
so can I ask the question has anyone
asked how she feels I mean I have
I feel like that's up to them to have
their conversations I'm not here to try
to make anybody feel uncomfortable and
although I'm I would hope she would say
something if she was to her own
boyfriend I think so too
fair points now we know how Scott feels
about all of this
it does take like a toll on me this trip
has so much pressure to watch it all
play out you'll have to tune in on
Sunday but we have a feeling it's all
gonna end up pretty okay after all this
isn't the first time Sofia has traveled
with Scott and Kourt just the first time
it's been filmed for the show I know
that we don't have to travel together
and I don't think that we will take
every trip together but it was totally
not awkward I feel like we are doing our
best to make everything feel super
normal for the kids and yeah Kourt and
Scott are committed to co-parenting like
pros I couldn't imagine raising three
children with somebody that I couldn't
speak to every day yeah I do not get how
people can do that just earlier this
year scott told ET this i think you just
gotta figure out really what's important
to you at the end of the day life is a
challenge and if you work at what you
want you can get it but it takes hard
work simple as that you can easily live
less of a life without working as hard
and that's a few all right guys that's
it for today if you want to continue
keeping up with all the things
Kardashians stick with ET until next
time I'm Katie Krauss and bye for now
you
[Applause]
[Music]